jean pierre guéno bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation sur rt france
alors on vient de le voir de nombreuses
statues ont été déboulonnées ou
dégradées dans le monde
quelle est votre réaction vis-à-vis de
ses actes mais écoutez on comprends tout
à fait cette soudaine mise d'émotion qui
submerge le monde depuis la mort de
l'assassinât de john floyd
ceci étant dit il ya tout un tas de gens
qui s'improvisent snipers et qui veulent
déboulonner les statues des plaques de
rues des baptisés des écoles des salles
de spectacle ça pose un problème énorme
on ne peut pas effacer savait voir une
cause surtout pas le faire parce que
sinon on déclenche and alzheimer de
l'histoire et de la mémoire
et ça c'est très grave alors le problème
il est très simple les pays riches bien
portants sont en train de redécouvrir
les horreurs de la colonisation
on écrit des livres sur label eco2
décolonisation en fait des tonnes
mais on oublie la colonisation et le
problème c'est que on a pas enseigné
jusqu'à ses 20 dernières années s'était
absenté des programmes scolaires et puis
on édulcore tout tente on se méfie de ce
qui nous gêne nous avons des points
d'accès dans notre histoire et dans
notre mémoire et ses parents les
effaçant qu'on arrivera à les régler il
faut crever les abcès il s'agit pas de
charger les générations actuelles les
générations futures
mais il s'agit simplement une fois pour
toutes de faire le point comme en
psychanalyse et puis quand c'est fait
quand on s'est assis sur le divan de la
mémoire
eh bien on passe à autre chose mais on
n'est jamais passé autre chose donc là
c'est un symptôme qui ressort il est pas
d'hier
1 ces histoires ces histoires sont assez
ancienne et et déboulonnage de statut
ont commencé depuis depuis une dizaine
d'années alors si on commence à régler
leurs comptes à des gens comme eux
colbert par exemple qui a dont il est
vrai que la plupart des têtes d'affiché
d'autres histoires sont des docteur
jekyll et mister hyde
ils véhiculent leur part d'ombré et leur
part de lumière
il convient de remettre les choses au
point de remettre les pendules à l'heure
mais de ne pas hypertrophié ni leur part
d'ombré leur part de lumière
elles sont là elles sont équilibrés
commerce et très la fois le grand
argentier d'un despote était louis xiv
c'est aussi l'auteur le concepteur du
code noir qui ne se contente pas de
régler leur compte aux eaux noires son
premier article régler leur compte aux
juifs donc c'est quelque chose d'assez
étonnant
messi aurait il sans contact que le
berre alors faut-il le faire avec des
gens qui ont donné leur nom à des
centaines de d'écoles de collèges deux
lycées en france
je pense par exemple à renan et à jules
ferry
je dois tout à jules ferry je suis un
fils de l'école de la république
mais jules ferry c'est aussi le grand
chantre du colonialisme et donc d'une
certaine façon de l' esclavage
il ya eu dans l'histoire de notre pays
des périodes paradoxale la révolution
qui milite pour les droits de l'homme
étaient pouvant ta ble ment rétrograde à
l'égard de l' esclavage et des droits
des esclaves des droits des doigts donc
il faut bien avoir cet esprit de nuance
aujourd'hui qu'il doit se traduire par
de la pédagogie
mais pendant très longtemps le dépannage
a été la marque d'un basculement
politique et pas mal d'exemples pendant
la révolution française puis les
dernières en date peut-être la plus
marquante celle de la statue de saddam
hussein en irak
est ce qu'aujourd'hui c'est le signe
d'une colère qui est bien présente
ancrée chez ces peuples ces populations
qui ont été a meurtri par l'oppression
la colère est légitime mais il faut se
méfier du pouvoir de la rue du pouvoir
de la meute
nous avons des historiens nous avons des
magistrats nous avons la chance de vivre
dans des systèmes démocratiques et il
faut se méfier de l'ère du zapping de
l'instant de tous qui flambent
il faut prendre le temps du temps il
faut respecter l'épaisseur du temps et
les règles de l'histoire tout simplement
qu'il faut savoir réagir comprendre ce
qui se passe mais agir et ne jamais
cesser de chercher à éduquer certes
certaines de ses statuts mérite d'être
peut-être à déplacer dans des musées
d'être commentées et d'être expliqué
tout comme les plaques de rues mais
certainement pas de disparaître car
quand on les fait disparaître quand on
les jette dans la boue des horreurs de
notre histoire
eh bien on gomme l'histoire est d'une
certaine façon c'est une forme de
révisionnisme
nous glissons alors dans l'amnésie
lorsque j'appelle alzheimer qui ne qui
la maladie du 21e siècle et qu'il menace
pas seulement les individus qui menace
les cultures les entreprises les
civilisations et l'histoire merci
beaucoup jean pierre guéno d'avoir réagi
sur notre antenne je rappelle que vous
êtes écrivain historien et journaliste